are there any Global or national Trends
in the next 5 to 10 years that aren't
talked about enough or you believe more
people should be paying attention to if
applicable how are you personally
preparing for this or these
shifts I would say one that comes to
mind is for lack of a better term
digital emotional surrogacy I'm sure
there is a sexier or more elegant term
for this
but the
inevitable development that we will have
I would say within the
next probably two
years photorealistic avatars that we can
interact with through say virtual
reality and if you haven't seen the demo
of the meta metaverse with Zuckerberg
with Lex fredman on his recent podcast
on YouTube that showcases what this can
look like I would encourage everybody to
at least watch the first five minutes to
get a taste of things to come with the
ability to interact with photorealistic
avatars Furthermore with the ability to
interact with photorealistic avatars who
might be your favorite celebrity like a
Taylor Swift with very convincing facial
expressions we are getting to a point
where companies like replica for
instance replica with a k at the end Ka
instead of CA where digital companions
are going to become for many people not
just a supplement to human interaction
but a replacement for human interaction
so I would say
that the loneliness
epidemic from my perspective is probably
only going to get more nuanced more
complex and
more challenging to address in some
respects because especially for people
like myself who are introverts I'm
taking active steps so I'll answer that
second part of your question to maybe
preemptively gird myself for this but
for those people who are already
intimidated or taxed by going out and
interacting with one person or groups of
people you could see the case for many
of them opting out completely and I
think uh we already have problems with
declining birth rates and there are many
countries that are below replacement
rates at this point so I am very curious
to see what societal impact that will
have the way I am counteracting that for
myself is booking things on the calendar
in advance and by by in advance I mean
at this point I'm probably six months
out booking trips booking time with
friends booking time with family getting
it on the calendar putting money behind
it doesn't have to be a lot of money but
enough money that you can can benefit
from the sunk cost fallacy and feel
invested so you won't cancel things and
really giving myself very few options
for opting out of social encounters I
know social interactions that I've
proven to myself over time are always in
my best interest even if I will drag my
feet to get there in the first place I
will leave being better off
so those are uh a few thoughts in terms
of Trends people are paying a lot of
attention to say Ai and Broad Strokes or
machine learning in Broad strokes but my
interest and certainly what I'm also
watching in my audience are are some of
the societal implications and the
psychological sort of mass psychological
implications of these things so you will
be able to take steps
to perhaps put a remote around yourself
to minimize the damage but this is
something to pay attention to and I
would also say that as these tools
become more and more convincing we've
Blown Away the Turing test it's already
been beaten or passed so as these tools
and machines become more and more
convincing more and more appealing I
think that there will be the very
natural impulse to offload more and more
of the things that we currently handle
in our own heads or manually and if you
want to preserve some of those abilities
you're going to have to decide to be
perhaps a selective leite or at least
for periods of time be a selective leite
how many people here would say their
parents are better at directions offline
not using Google Maps than the younger
generations and I would imagine a lot of
people would raise their hand and this
is perhaps not controversial because
people have decided to embrace something
like Google Maps or many other
competitors to help them with
convenience and accuracy and so on
however if you don't use it you lose it
and it's
easy to embrace
convenience and not recognize severe
atrophy of capabilities until it's very
hard to reverse so
I think that that is a meta
awareness that needs to be developed as
we are interacting with these
increasingly seductive and Powerful
tools so long answer but these are
things that I think
about